[Music]
how much did you bring with you
what money-wise how much did you bring
with you so you could have zero dollars
[Music]
she seems like yeah she was so rude
working here you would have to probably
be a pretty cool
person that would be hard i mean a hard
line of work
i would not choose it let's work our way
backwards
virginia's governor today responded to
critics after a move by democrats to
ease restrictions
on late late-term abortions the infant
would be delivered
uh the infant would be kept comfortable
the infant would be resuscitated if
that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue
between the physicians and the mothers
abortion
it's been a hot topic in the news
recently thanks to a new law in new york
allowing abortion
all the way up until birth
as often with media driven national
dialogue most people are just yelling at
each other
this is such a fallacy of the right wing
abortion on demand is a made-up campaign
slogan
to get people scared about something
that is actually having to do with
health care and a woman's
right this is about a woman's right to
choose and you as a man should not have
a single say in that
hi everybody my choice
i'm a nasty woman but what are we really
talking about here
and is the new york law really all that
shocking
now it's true most americans identify as
pro-choice but when asked on late-term
abortions those numbers flip
so putting new york aside what does
abortion look like elsewhere in the
country
i'll show you it's that simple we have
here with us marielle
marielle and kat you're going to be here
moral support you are as i understand it
uh
with child i am marielle is 25 weeks
pregnant
with her baby rose at 25 weeks rose is
well developed she already has hair on
her head she can get the hiccups
and even recognize her mother's voice
from the womb
rose also has a viability of 50 to 80
percent
in seven states with more on the way it
is
perfectly legal to abort rose for any
reason
worse it's easy all that would need to
happen today for you to actually go
through with this abortion would
be to say the word yes yep so this video
is simple there are 800 000 to
1 million abortions performed every year
in the united states with thousands tens
of thousands classifying as late term
we took a hidden camera to an abortion
clinic in colorado where late term
abortions have been legal for years
to show you exactly what it is that they
we and you
are talking about but right away we ran
into some
oddly opaque hiccups big security we
don't allow any person's bags cell
phones like literally none of that can
come in with you
will not bring like snacks or water or
anything nothing
like the airport the only thing you can
bring in is a photo id
okay that's right no phones purses
jackets hats so we had to cut a hole in
marielle's shirt and make do
we then sent her back into the clinic
where she was briefed in the likely
procedure but
was mostly relegated to the waiting room
and that's when something dumbfounding
happened
meet we'll call her patient x
how far along are you probably 28.
and as we later found out it was
actually worse to get your ultrasound
yeah
like putting in 32 weeks that's right
just like thousands every day across the
country this woman was going to end her
32 week
that's eight months her eight month old
baby's life
for reference this is what a 32 week old
potential rose looks like
fully developed entirely viable and
without a doubt not a clump of cells
or a zygote but a baby and perfectly
legal to kill
but it's one thing to look at laws on a
page let's simply let the nurses
and patient ex tell you what this
experience is like not on a podium or a
news panel but behind closed doors when
they think
no one is watching they have to do like
an injection
like in your stomach that stops the
fetal heartbeat
i mean they said it varies sometimes it
can take 10 minutes sometimes it can
take a couple hours
okay so this is essentially all the
different services depending upon
whether you okay
first trimester second trimester third
trimester is more medically indicated
like if there are problems with the
problem okay
see if there's something diagnosed okay
um this is what each one of our patients
gets
and there's nothing wrong i mean there's
nothing wrong with everyone's
he's fine there's nothing wrong with him
like they did like the down syndrome
and they ran all that's all blood work
it all came out fine when you
essentially walk around for three days
with a dead baby
oh my god in your stomach why don't you
get sepsis
like i mean sepsis the blood like
infection like
with the dead i remember like my
concerns and i kind of asked the doctor
and they kind of like
kind of shuffed it off like it was no
big deal are you guys okay
yeah we're just waiting for ultrasound
will she say anything
[Music]
movement of people that get into the
waiting rooms and then sit in the
waiting room
oh
yeah that's ridiculous
there's no way i've like went two
different times it's not like i haven't
tried to take the one time this time i
was 10 weeks
i couldn't take the pill they couldn't
get me in for a surgical thing and
trying to find the time to get back up
do it so that was number one number two
i went at 18 weeks i was ready for
thanksgiving
and that doctor didn't feel comfortable
doing it because of that scar tissue
and so i told that guy to look at that
in there and he's like yeah it's really
thick on one side it's
really thin on the other music but then
they're
like well there's a hospital nearby
like that's what i'm just like
i mean it's a uterus that's a muscle
that's a very like
delicate like i mean
you can have peripherated or what well
you know that's scary what if something
happens to me
should i do it should i not i know my
husband the whole time was like you're
gonna practice like you don't need to do
this like
you know we'll it'll be fine but i'm
like you're not the one that has to be
at home raising that
i do just been between my husband like
you know and he's just kind of like well
i'll do whatever you want
it hasn't been real like super you know
it's like i don't really have any good
friends that i could like
you know in a small town so it's like
you see he made me go get like a sauna
at like 24 weeks because he was like you
need to like
see if everything's okay because if
you're gonna have to keep playing and
you make sure
it's okay you know everything was fine
oh my god is he not gonna love me
anymore
like if i do this yeah because he's told
me you know kayla listen you can't just
get pregnant and
do that like this is not you know dude
it's not right
you know he can't get pregnant and then
just terminate like
he's like i thought you wanted one more
kid and i was like you know i kind of
did it but then when i thought about it
it almost took me getting pregnant to be
like
oh my god i can't do this like i had my
life was my
two kids was perfect when i explained
that to you the two boys like
something happened to your mom look she
had another baby in her tummy and she
was trying to
i mean how would you i mean he's like
how would i explain it to your mom and
dad
or my parents we would have you stay
closer if we started the steps like
actually
like at a hotel then yeah there's one
that's just up the road that our
patients stay at when they're here
okay because they'll be dilating your
cervix and causing some changes
okay um and then if something came up we
wouldn't want you to have to try to get
you know from denver up to us
in like four minutes instead of 40.
where are you staying
at the university okay
yeah that's it it's not awful but it's
like
kind of sketch but they that's where
they recommended me
oh it's not very far from here so i feel
like i'm very selfish like
doing this that's why i'm having such a
hard time with it i was raised catholic
like it's like i'm going against
everything that i was
ever brought up to you know what i mean
i'm doing this basically for my kids
like
you know do you feel like you're gonna
do it
yeah i mean i just i mean i can't roll
this way and it's like
we already have two other children and i
was like i don't
i can't do this again like i cannot
start all over again
and that's supposed to put the injection
to me yeah
oh lord jesus please stop i'm having
this abortion be safer baby
[Music]
we all still pray here that patient x
didn't go through with it but like the
thousands of women and doctors
previously mentioned
she probably did see the national
dialogue usually centers around
medically necessary abortions people who
are seeking an abortion
that late in their pregnancy are women
who either
are at severe health risk because of
going through with a pregnancy
or because their fetus is facing severe
abnormalities it may be incompatible
with with life it may be unviable to
live outside the womb
but those are rare or we often hear
about the cases of rape and incest but
they never ask about those anyway
even more often we hear about how late
term abortions only account for a small
percentage of those performed
only 1.3 percent of abortions happen
during or after 21 weeks of pregnancy
and there's not like
third trimester abortions like that's
not a thing take into account that
nearly 1 million abortions are performed
in the united states on any given year
that's more than all homicides
or suicides drug overdoses alcohol
related deaths and car accidents
combined if you multiplied them all by
four that's ten to twelve thousand
viable fully developed baby boys
baby girls baby roses
now i get that many of these women are
lied to a lot of them don't rightly know
what's actually happening in that
medical room but what about the doctor
how does a doctor perform abortion after
abortion after abortion at 20 weeks 25
weeks 29
weeks a full eight months day after day
when he ends these lives he sees
their faces he sees their fingers their
toes
their eyes this isn't a statistic on a
worksheet but a real
autonomous human being what kind of a
doctor harms that
well in this case dr warren hearn
he started his abortion clinic in 1973
right after the passing of roe v wade
and has been proudly
serving abortions ever since even boldly
trumpeting his willingness to perform
abortions at 34 weeks that's eight and a
half months
now this is all far beyond the scope of
what most americans think they're
advocating when they claim to be
pro-choice so how does a doctor who took
the hippocratic oath justify this well
it's pretty easy if you're a
neo-environmentalist like dr hearn who
sees human beings as
actual cancer now this is all far beyond
the scope of what most americans think
they're advocating when they claim to be
pro-choice
because who in their right mind in
today's american mainstream left or
right would support this kind of pure
unadulterated barbarism for the answer
to that
you just have to ask any of the
prominent figureheads
of today's dnc potentially
your next president
[Music]
[Music]
you